ever since its discovery in 1985 the
springtime ozone hole over Antarctica
has been an insistent reminder of
humankind's ability to cause
environmental harm but the wound has
begun to heal there's now evidence that
the hole is shrinking the problem began
in the 1980s with chlorine containing
chemicals used in dry cleaning
refrigerators and aerosol cans in order
to destroy ozone the chlorine needs to
be activated with two extra ingredients
ultraviolet light and stratospheric
clouds made of nitric acid particles
that only form an extreme cold
that's why Antarctic ozone destruction
Peaks in October when winter cold gives
way to springtime light the 1987
Montreal Protocol phased out the
chemicals and measurements have shown
them declining in the atmosphere not
researchers have found evidence of the
intended consequence shrinkage in the
ozone hole using satellites ground-based
instruments and ozone measuring weather
balloons they showed that since 2000 the
Antarctic coal in September shrunk by 4
million square kilometres an area bigger
than India an extra challenge was
showing that the shrinkage was due to
the drop in chemicals using a 3d
atmospheric model the researchers
separated out the effects of weather and
volcanic emissions which can also
destroy ozone the model helps explain
anomalously large ozone holes like the
one in October 2015 which was largely
due to the eruption earlier that year of
the calbuco volcano in southern Chile
although the hole has begun to heal the
chlorine and bromine containing
chemicals have long atmospheric
lifetimes so scientists don't expect the
hole to close up completely until 2050
at the earliest